attack on titan does many things right
but the show does its transformations
too damn well to triumph anything
it might be the build up the conclusion
or the scene itself but each of these
managed to give us that hyped feeling we
get when the shifters transform to their
titan selves so today we're going to
take a look at 10 of the best attack on
titan transformations
note that i'll only be including
complete transformations here so
sorry miss tiber you'll have to take a
back seat here more attack on titan and
other anime contents coming up so don't
forget to subscribe to the channel if
you haven't done so already because you
can be updated as soon as we release a
new video
now without further await let's get to
the top 10 attack on titan
transformations
[Music]
starting off we have the transformation
of ymir in season two
one of the many good things about attack
on titan season two is giving the
spotlight to minor characters
while aaron and his gang were still
suffering the consequences of the female
titan we get to focus on some minor
characters like connie historia ymir and
the two traitors themselves and ever
since the third episode we've been
getting hints that yamir has a rather
tragic past behind her but then
come the events of the utgard tower
which forces her to reveal her true face
yes this freckle girl who was a minor
character one season ago
turned out to be a titan shifter now
this transformation may not be as
majestic as the ones that are about to
come
after this but this one established that
there were other titan shifters hidden
in the crowd
also let's not forget yamir blew her
disguise in order to protect historia
and i can see why years later people
still ship these two as the best couple
this was the best moment of yamir's
character
and once again attack on titan proved to
us that minor characters aren't just
people drawn into the background
next up we have aaron's transformation
inside the cave to save his squad
remember aaron from season three
he wasn't the silent and cunning main
character you see these days when pain
and realism hit him hard
he broke down crying it's not the
manliest thing to do but rodris can give
some pretty hard mental torture for a
boy who just learned his father was a
murderer but when rod transforms and
heads out on a rampage it's up to aaron
to once again
save his mates levi as usual gives him a
choice to make his own decisions and
even though aaron didn't have the best
iq back in the day he was smart enough
to know he was the only one who could
save his crewmates from their near
deaths
crying and screaming at the same time
eren transforms to the attack titan and
crystallizes the entire cave there
weren't many errand moments in the first
part of season 3 so this transformation
once again managed to secure his place
as the main character of the show
coming in at number eight it's aaron's
first titan transformation
you should always leave a good
impression on your first time right but
in this case it's tough to think about
impressions
when you're drowning in a pool of blood
along with corpses aaron was altruistic
enough to save his best friend but can
he survive the repercussions
luckily he doesn't have to suffer much
because there's a titan hidden in his
body the sight of blood and dead bodies
trigger the memories of his mother's
death
and our protagonist comes right out from
the titan's mouth in his new muscular
form
we need to give credit to wit studio for
animating the form of the attack titan
in all of its glory it looked deadly
angry and the looks alone were enough to
kill anyone besides the dead titan also
learned a valuable lesson
always chew what you eat
[Music]
next up we have the evil father taking
things to the next level that's none
other than rod reese's transformation
now if you thought rodriguez had done
enough to make him the most hated
character of the season
then you were wrong as his plans fail
and his daughter breaks his bones he
licks the last drop of the titan serum
to handle everything by himself
and as it turns out even a few drops
were enough to transform him into the
ugliest titan in the series
right in front of aaron and historia
this evil father transforms into the
largest titan humanity has ever seen
if you take a look at things from rod's
perspective this is perfectly
justifiable his daughter left him his
lineage was probably going to wither
away and his only option is to
pardon the pun to keep moving forward
but this time he keeps moving forward as
a titan
larger than the colossal titan itself
blowing off steam
and wreaking havoc now why does that
sound familiar
coming in at number six is reiner's
rather depressing transformation
in season four honestly why can't anyone
let this man die in peace
we have characters literally claiming
their desire to live because they were
born to this world but here
our character only wants to die with all
his burdens thrown away
so to quickly recap eren's now playing
the bad guy role he ate the warhammer
titan in the most
brutal way possible and is about to do
the same to the jaw titan
so who's the main character of the marly
yard none other than rhino braun when
the children cry for his help he needs
to let go of all of those suicidal
thoughts and stand up for a fight for
anyone who watched this episode without
knowing the story it might look like the
hero of the anime finally stood up to
fight the villain let's forget what
happened afterward and instead
focus on rhinos rather pessimistic never
giving up
[Music]
attitude
next up is armin's transformation when
you're the colossal titan
the transformation should be colossal as
well or at least it should have a
colossal impact does armin count
one quarter of the city nuke and dead
bodies piled up as colossal he sure does
because you can see it from his face
this transformation happens when armin
transforms at the shores of liberio
destroying ships and nuking the entire
port in the process
now this transformation may not have
screams and rapid animation to back it
up but what matters is the destruction
it's caused
even though it falls short of action and
buildup in terms of the transformations
in this list
it was still impactful enough to show
that when the devils of paradise attack
they attack with everything they've got
and here we all thought aaron was the
only one who could make a grand entrance
[Music]
uh
coming in at number four is annie's
transformation after the revelation and
we all knew this girl was up to
something ever since she hesitated
walking into the tunnel but then magasa
outright claimed she was the female
titan
and that's the moment the cards turned
and we all knew hell was about to break
loose if the female titan killed half of
the survey corpse inside the forest
imagine what she could do inside a city
full of civilians but the very thing
everyone dreads happens as annie
leonhart pricks her finger and
transforms while blasting off his
attackers
the reason this transformation stands
out from the crowd is mainly because of
annie herself
irwin and others knew she was the female
titan and ambushed her but our girl
still had the time to transform thanks
to her quick thinking it was the peak
moment of the big revelation
the time when we realized everything is
about to turn upside down and the moment
everything the arc built up fell into
place
and when she transformed i'm sure your
look was similar to eren's and
leonhardt right there and then
transformed literally
with a bang
taking our number three spot is erin's
transformation to defeat
the female titan let's move
chronologically right into this next
event so when annie's revealed to be the
female titan and they hatch a really bad
plan to capture her she transforms and
goes on a rampage
and there's only one person who can stop
her but sadly this so-called hero is
trapped between rocks in a pool of blood
i know
not in the best shape remember aaron
from season one he was much less mature
than his current self and thought rage
could solve every problem but turns out
rage
could grant you an awesome
transformation sequence the death of his
mother has always been aaron's
motivation to defeat the titans and the
visions of her death once again give him
strength he screams into the sky and
literally calling out the lightning he
transforms into the attack titan
with the incredible samano track in the
background this is without a doubt one
of the best attack on titan
transformations
[Music]
next up is the transformation during the
big reveal that's none other than the
transformation of reiner and bertolt
no wonder years later this scene still
gives us the chills even though there's
one more scene to triumph the music the
art the character expressions
everything managed to stand out to make
this one of the best transformations
ever you might argue the transformation
lasted only a few seconds but it was the
build up that mattered the most
all those small crews we gathered from
season two exploded right in our faces
and reina casually said they were the
two titan shifters who destroyed the
wall
when the cards were laid out on the
table and mukasa took her usual
aggressive approach the two
malian warriors had nothing to do but to
transform into their titan cells
it was tragic fearful and epic at the
same time hats off to wit studio for
animating this in its full glory because
years later any of us can still watch
this transformation and be
thrilled about what a masterpiece attack
on titan is
our number one pick for the best attack
on titan transformation
is none other than aaron's
transformation in mali
you knew this was coming didn't you if
the rhino bertolt reveal was with
studio's best scene
then this was where mappa showed their
skills in terms of directing i'd still
say the previous transformation triumphs
this one
but aaron's transformation here carried
a lot of weight
marley's declaration of war ironically
turned out to be paradise's own
declaration of freedom
similar to the reiner and bertone reveal
the whole episode took the time to build
up the scene from aaron's speech to
willie's declaration
and when aaron transformed and came out
of the building with an explosion that
was the moment we realized we were
experiencing
peak attack on titan ladies and
gentlemen anime
cannot get better than this
so there goes our list for the best
attack on titan transformations of all
time
if your favorite transformation wasn't
here in this list drop a comment below
and feel free to argue about what you
thought was the best from this list as
well
as usual if you enjoyed the video don't
forget to subscribe and hit the bell
notification so you can be updated as
soon as we release a new video that's it
for today anime fans
and i'll see you in the next video
you